you
all right the Internet is up and running
in this guy got that magic number there
20250 that's a cool picture
this guy has look at that all right
let's stay flexible here I'm gonna go
with the kingside fiend cut oh not yet
commit any of my center pawns castles c4
all right hang on for a second
let's do this
in case of e4 I could play Knight g5 and
scoop that pawn up I think I'd be able
to hammer away at it by g5 9c3 Queen c2
and I don't think there'd be enough
defense okay I guess just d3 maybe h6
has to be inserted to stop that okay I
don't see any reason not to just Castle
here hmm it's black going to kill my
king here with Bishop h3 I feel like
playing b4 I'm gonna go forward that
before and
takes root b1 it's not really a gambit
is it all right so let's give that night
a kick it [ __ ] takes King takes of
course night here
I'm night here I think I'm gonna play
III I don't want to take because after
the recapture I don't really have a
great square for my night okay
I'm thinking about efore right now what
about Eve
or and then I could start to think about
95 hmm yeah II four and you know it
maybe even D four if d 4e for my natal
get kicked around if I'm gonna play this
position without my light-square bishop
it's gonna be nice to have my pawns on
light squares coordinated with this guy
so how does how does white finish
development are they still gonna run
after my King I don't want to invite the
Queen into my position with the bishop
takes oh boy okay well you know what I
could do maybe maybe I could invite the
Queen into my position with this is the
follow-up ninety five this is a newly
weakened square
might want to do that oh and you know
what as a follow-up
how could my knight be kicked from this
square f6 but if I plant my knight on d5
one day and take I'll have a pawn
supporting this square
I think getting rid of my knight will be
difficult thinking about Bishop takes
Queen takes Knight g5 let's just try
this I need to get rid of that Queen
okay and now this was my idea h6 all
right no you know what I should just do
h4 I was gonna do h6 and meet h4 with
the g4 hmm I'm thinking about h4 instead
yeah let's go with the h4 I'm not even
gonna allow this pawn to move you've
gone far enough
always a delicate move to make you know
I have to still anticipate black goes on
the opposite side and so I don't want
these files to open up towards my king
of course so this is a piece in blacks
position can't feel too comfortable oh
and you know what you can't even Castle
queenside because of the pressure on f7
so he's a piece of big bother this guy
right here as follow-up moves Bishop e3
maybe King g2 is this not gonna do
something dangerous over here
not sure what about this
just open it up the d4 I have a lead in
development I don't know how that's
really helping me I'm gonna go with this
his pond could fall but I like the
pressure over here
I like maybe the pressure on this square
I could be getting like Knight takes
pawn takes alright really going there I
guess just developed my bishop not quite
sure down to less than two so he could
get rid of my knight
maybe Queen to f3 was better yeah I'm
not sure it's a tough call here I could
be dropping yeah I wasn't really going
to be too afraid of this move
maybe I should be afraid okay hang on
hang on for just a second
Bishop back yeah I think I want
on to him I was gonna be trying
something like Queen f3 but I was afraid
of f6 at this point if f6 now where does
my night off I go here he's unprotected
like if I played Queen f3 f6 and then
all right if I play Queen f3 I think
there would be f6 Knight here and then
something like Knight takes bishop and
then the Queen could come down on h3
let's chin a lot of time here hmm f6
all right f6 it is I don't really want
to go to this unprotected square so
let's go here yeah I think I should get
right back here let's do this first
though and then I think my knight is the
one who needs to get back here and be
annoying this is the weakest Square in
blacks position I want to have a piece
there all right I think I need to just
chop this guy up and get my bishop over
here to defend should be okay Knight
here maybe well this is getting scary I
could kick this night away too
oh you know I think I better try was
night g6 at that point we're gonna see
cuz now I have my Bishop as a defender
bishop g3 okay let's just back him up
here I want to get rid of this Knight
he still has to be a pain this guy
alright if I do this I'm getting hit
with the fork hmm
and if I don't Knight f4 is that gonna
be a pain it seems like it maybe I need
to stop that feel like I can miss
anything at any moment with these
Knights being next to my king hmm I
might want to do f3 or f4 this move
first kick the night away I have it
covered with my knight 36 seconds is not
a lot and Queen here next just to cover
everything
maybe d4 I don't want to give the g4
square up so Knight f6 Queen - with d4
maybe something else to consider some
some sacrifice here I don't think it's
working
alright let's go here I have this square
covered with my knight
let's get rid of him we could come in
here
maybe that would have been an idea let's
push Queen here Queen g2 even on time
alright they should start to be much
better at this point
I have a huge center of pawns you have
to go fast I'll get all my pieces in
let's just push gonna be taken over here
my Brookes right where I want them I
just keep pushing I guess Queen wow they
blended that how's a mouse slip no yeah
that was tight GG let's go back into a
bigger board for starters let's bring
that up I did not feel comfortable at
all during that game I got way too scary
with that H pawn being thrown down on my
King game history
and let's go into it like so alright
let's look at it from your perspective
and a good game okay so we have some
type of in English here huh I wonder if
I could have immediately gone with night
here now I'm sorry I have to defend c4
so okay it's there in time to stop
Knight g5 I don't know I'm not even sure
what I could even suggest in this
position or in this game I guess this is
just a quick combination of moves to
certainly be aware of after h5 it does
leave this vulnerable so normally I
wouldn't want to invite the Queen in but
if I could kick her away with tempo like
this and then follow up with h4 like I
did in the game or even h3 width to meet
like this right here maybe even h3 I was
thinking at this point to me h4 with g4
maybe that would have been a better try
then I have to worry about the night
getting into the g4 square so that this
is another moment where I would maybe
want to reconsider on the black side
though I thought what did I think I
thought that hmm
this point right here I thought that
after f5 this f4 move as soon as takes I
thought Knight g6 would have caused me
problems because how do I defend this
this was going to scare me
if night ji6 was played I really don't
know what I would do actually I do have
an idea if night g6 I was maybe gonna go
f5 hit the night he grabs here but then
the Queen is kind of cut off because of
this structure and at the same time I
have the e6 square for my night before I
was talking about I know landing here
and if he's ever taken I have to ID
recapture and then have a support point
on e6 but I guess I could establish that
with my epon with this variation after
or not my epon my jeep on taking and
then pushing would have been a
possibility so I'm not sure what to even
suggest as something well I guess it's
getting pretty deep into the position
suggesting something but I think at this
point as soon as as soon as this capture
comes I think immediately hit at the
weakness because this capture is
inviting a new piece in here for the
defense this is where I started to feel
at least a little bit more comfortable
like I mean I'm there in time if you
were to say let's play Knight g6 now I
back up and I'm defending h4 but one
move earlier I don't know it's tricky
that's for sure and I don't know if
there's anything more here that you were
missing he's certainly tough to work
around this is a hole this is not yet a
hole because I have f3 and okay watch
over f3 and kick your knight away and we
just get pushing and running like crazy
at this point timewise and the worst is
past for sure I think there was one
window for you to put some more pressure
on me and that was right here and then
from there it really started to shift
maybe it's already still better for
white but like a g6 would have scared me
that's for sure
alright I'm really not sure what more to
add with
other than good game night here this
might be a good spot for the night I
also have thoughts of just pushing
forward again with the safe trying to
maybe open up a file upon e5 pawn takes
rook takes my ruck I'll have some pieces
in mind